alrighty here team light versus me okay
well switching gears I will not be
rattling off a bunch of stuff quickly
here hopefully it's a more
understandable and meaningful we are in
nimes Oh indian defence land now and I
could castle I could also consider I
believe playing d5 here but I'm not
really a big fan of doing that when the
bishop comes out to pin I like having
available to me the possibility to
double the sea ponds and not let these
ponds on double themselves and that's
why I'm saying that I'm not too fond of
playing this d5 move when the bishop has
played here I double the ponds then with
this guy here they could be undone so
anyhow I think I want to just run in for
this capture unprovoked and look forward
to building up the typical structure one
that's going to consist of having ponds
on dark squares to compensate for my not
having a dark square Bishop anymore I
think this is the right move to
beginning with to begin with excuse me
and i'm not sure what i want to do with
my night it might might be prevented
might be prevented from playing to c6
with this move but there's a serious
downside to doing that what is that down
side we can see 5 and my night could
make use of it my way of d 7 or a 6 and
just two moves um now 196 and what else
96 castle I want to be cautious of maybe
this pawn push and then a bishop playing
here maybe I could consider what what
could I consider if i play Queenie seven
then this idea of night here to here is
out the window because of a possible
Queen check in my night is picked off so
what about c59 c6 first not sure I'm
going to try this throw another pond on
a dark square one thing that I kind of
as a last mental note the thing that
kind of just said you know just go with
C 5 is that if I'm able to fix it if I'm
able to plant a pond right here on c5
and just keep him there I don't have to
worry about these guys ever pushing so
there's like a little section here
that's obstructing the white movement on
the queenside so I don't have this
square available pretty much this is
going to be his only spot and I don't
know if I even want to castle maybe
queen here is best now supporting this
point this is the one pond that could
really end up being hit real soon and I
think um I think it might have been in a
faster game okay I don't want to deal
with the pen I think it might have been
in a faster game i have played against
uh a GM i don't know if it was a blitz
or a bullet but something with this g4
move came into play g4 night g3 so i'm a
bit aware of that kind of an idea and
with the night maybe looking to play to
this square I'm maybe a bit more
hesitant to Castle kingside with the
center closed I don't the play is going
to ensue on the wing so that's another
another reason why I would want to be on
the lookout for that I think getting my
night here and then f8 quickly is good
now in that variation where I said I saw
Knight g4 upon g4 and then night g3 I
think my night was over here on a five
it was first on c6 it got kicked away
and then I play
here instead of just preventing knight
c6 altogether so I think this is a good
journey for this night to go on I have a
close eye on this square and I want to
make sure that my bishop is in a spot to
watch out for a night eventually getting
to this f5 square now that i have
another night over here maybe a bit more
inclined to just run forward with
castling i do have to watch out for this
pressure that black or excuse me that
white has on this black Ponte b7 and
also now this that is a problem isn't it
let me force our White's hand force them
to Castle pressure on these two points I
don't know if this is best but i wanna i
want to follow up with this move i think
now that is something I definitely did
not expect pawn push g3 night here h 4
i'm in trouble interesting interesting
what about rook here and then pawn push
or just no pawn push at all I'm just
going to come back I think if i if i
play g5g three filed by h4 was going to
be very difficult to me so now at least
white is a bit shaky with that King
position there might be some tricks on
like a pawn push maybe I could sack my
bishop capture a couple times and then
get this pretty valuable dark squared
bishop and actually night here and then
Queen check i think is available Queen
check and do some weakness if this pawn
moves then eventually I can move this
light squared Bishop now if the white
Brooks are doubled on this pond right
here becomes difficult for me to develop
the light squared Bishop but on the flip
side of things I think it's maybe a case
of too much material devoted in one
section of the boy
and I have to keep a real close eye on
my clock one minute six and I think
maybe I could be pushing this pond no I
lose control of that so let's try this
maybe night here to here is available if
this pond pushes I could take if the
palm recaptures i have a check on h4 i
don't know that there's a way to break
through at this point now i'm going to
Castle if they sack here I could bring
my queen here immediately and challenge
that Queen I'm in a spot that's one of
the reasons why i went with night h7 i
really can't do this this Bishop is
going to spring to life maybe I could
play night here let's try double ponds I
can maybe get this pawn up in my kingdom
g7 my truck to a che I don't know where
there's going to be progress against be
7 i'm not seeing how white can crash
through at this point they are tying up
both bishop and rook but when you i mean
if you do a number count this is 10
points constraining 8 and now this
square oh this is this is a problem this
is a this is dropping this pond and I
believe that's uh is that the beginning
of the end right here it may very well
be the beginning of the end right here
yeah this is this is trouble now because
I'm taking here i'm on the Queen and I'm
going to do it with this pond noticing
me this night so that I could follow up
with g5 in lock the position and that's
ideally that's it that's exactly what I
would want a locked position since I
have since I have what I have the night
so if i do this well if i do this is
this night going to be captured i don't
think it can the king is really short on
squares maybe this and then queen here
or queen here right away something with
this battery putting pressure on this
pond i think right now it's attacked
once defended once i'm considering it in
my mind unprotected i'm just going to
take here and then i think the last
piece of the puzzle here the last step
is to just sink my night
on this square those there there might
be something more direct with taking or
queen hear something but I I'm just
seeing that this position right here
being much easier to play just just
focusing on getting my night to a good
square and this is very well supported
and we could be turning out to be in a
position where what I have a good versus
bad Bishop last decision I'm going to go
with this I'm giving myself a reason to
not capture towards the center because I
want to get my queen here even though
there's more prospects for this Bishop
to come in this direction this is still
a bit um I still have some reorganizing
to do I could do this because I could
take and i'll be on the Queen just in
the nick of time right there I'm there
to defend pond push pond push and now I
believe I break open in this way let's
try this again I think I want Oh what's
the time situation rook over okay I
think things are working out now the
rook could take that pond no i can't i
have Bishop takes pawn time situation oh
oh oh oh there was a bishop check move
there's still as a bishop check move
there isn't a bishop check move time
situation Clark where the sneaky moves
pounds going to be sneaky isn't it you
take that oh this pot is really fast
Oh their downtime I kept thinking that
they're going to sneak in that little
pond move just right there the the final
position wow what a what a good game
working having to work pay close
attention to both wings in that game we
saw good game let's um let's go back
flip the board and I want to see how
things were from your perspective and
maybe we could learn a thing or two
along the way here just from this
five-minute game so very early on what
did we have this structural change okay
structural change out on the dark square
Bishop planting ponds on dark not a bad
idea and my queen here to watch over
this square h6 stop the pins and okay
well with this lock center now as soon
as this happens where did the attention
turn as soon as this happened after
these moves blooms c5 and then d five
centers locked and it's even more so
locked after this this move by the way
I'm not so sure about I wonder if
there's something better like clean here
clean here first and then night e 2 2
g-3 or e to g for first and then night
g3 look into that again i was seeing a
pretty strong player play that against
me so just throwing out some rough ideas
here and in any event the center is
locked up now and play is going to ensue
on the ABC files or fgh actually more
like the a or b files nothing's going on
with the C file the a or b is going to
maybe open up or any one of these F G or
H files so now what I have to be
cautious I really did not want to castle
too soon my opponent was being stubborn
I don't know how much progress i make
you know i'm just probing for weaknesses
here basically I was kind of liking
seeing the g3 move so you know I can
maybe be getting to this square maybe
just don't do that move what's a what's
a good plan here
I don't know what a good plan is maybe
hmm it may seem a bit awkward but maybe
there's an idea for the white side to
actually take a hike with your king go
on a little hike by way of d 1 C 2 B 2
and a 1 tuck your king in the corner and
then throw this rook over here and then
look for maybe some F for break or h3g
for type of stuff maybe that's an idea
with this again locked center maybe
there is this idea available to you it's
a strategic position trying to come up
with the good plans maybe that's one you
could look into a king wok throw your
look over here and then blast things
open I wonder about that but it is a
five minute game tough to really
calculate all that and then this is
starts to become downhill from here so
instead that pond move I guess just hang
tight here I guess you're gonna have to
deal with the piece getting to this
square or maybe you could stop it
altogether with night to g1 but it seems
like you're maybe a bit on the defensive
so I'm wondering maybe if that King run
to the a1 square is not a bad idea just
a thought okay